[Música]
[Aplausos]
no sé si a ustedes les pasa que me
gustaría que ver que sí pero soy yo la
que más duro se juzga tengo una vocecita
dentro de mi cabeza que cada vez que
siento que estoy cantando bien esa
vocecita llega conmigo y me dice cuando
estás horrible si siento que estoy
bailando bien esa vocecita ya conmigo y
me dice bailas espantoso estás haciendo
el ridículo si sueño con dar una texto
esa voz me dice imposible no lo intentes
no lo hagas
entonces entra a una lucha constante de
llegar con esa vocecita callarla y decir
que importa que puede salir mal como lo
estoy intentando hacer en este momento
pero bueno
de chiquita
yo viví una infancia un poco complicada
me quedé a vivir sola con mi nana y la
verdad es que yo a ella la veía triste
y me preocupaba mucho eso me preocupaba
mucho que se sintiera sola o se
deprimiera entonces yo siempre buscaba
la forma de hacerla de ellos de hacerla
feliz
y la verdad es que ella no era la única
que estaba triste yo también lo estaba
pero siempre tenía esa vocecita que
también me decía que importa que puede
salir mal entonces tenía un gran sueño
que era entrar a un concurso de talentos
de pequeños talentos entonces con esa
vocecita que me decía que importa que
puede salir mal me intenté e hice lo que
más me gustaba hacer en ese momento que
era bailar árabes y entonces llegué con
mis activistas a la primera fase y
empecé a mover mis caderas pum pum pum
pum pum todo con esta voz que también me
decía no lo vas a lograr estás haciendo
el ridículo y decían no importa todo va
a salir bien lo voy a intentar entonces
pasé la primera fase y yo dije no
inventes este sueño se va a cumplir o
sea voy a llegar al éxito con este
programa no entonces yo con ese sueño
tenía 8 años o sea se vale soñar no
entonces pase a la segunda fase y con
esa misma actitud perdón te la segunda
fase y la pasé y entonces dije ya siento
que voy a ganar este concurso y de
pronto recuerdo ver a los productores
con la cabeza
y sentir que mi sueño se había terminado
y sobre todo darle la razón a esa voz
que me dijo te lo dije no lo ibas a
lograr
en ese momento llegó mi mamá y me dijo
estoy increíble o es la que más bonito
bailaba árabe la única que bailaba árabe
o sea allí y es obvio que me va a decir
eso es como su chamba es mi mamá decirme
que soy perfecta entonces después de
darle la razón a esa vocecita ese reino
malvada muy malvada
tuve que seguir adelante y tuve que
encontrar otra cosa que me gustará más
siempre me ha gustado hacer reír a las
personas que me rodean sobre todo a mi
mamá ya mis hermanas entonces siempre me
disfrazaba y me grababa haciendo locuras
como esta
[Música]
eso
ah
muy bien
dónde voy a meter
y yo
entonces yo hacía estos vídeos con tal
de hacer reír a mi familia y la verdad
es que siempre tuve bastante tiempo
libre porque yo estudié escuela abierta
entonces tenía mucho tiempo para hacer
tonterías las cuales me encantaban en el
2013 surge una aplicación de unos vídeos
que duraban nada yo tenía muchísimo
tiempo libre entonces dije que importa
que puede salir mal los voy a empezar a
hacer
de pronto esta aplicación se viraliza y
de un momento a otro
llegué con mi mamá y le dije qué crees
que pasó hija yo tengo más seguidores de
los amigos que tengo en facebook cuántos
tienes 300 por hacer esto mi papá y
y
iannetta levi's si tienes tu casa se
sobreentiende
y de un momento a otro ya no era sólo
una aplicación era un medio para
comunicarme con personas que me
escuchaban personas de muchos lugares
que nunca imaginé conocer y mi trabajo
hasta el día de hoy
es impresionante porque el hip hop
empecé a vivir de hacer algo que me
divertía muchísimo hacer ya los 15 años
ya podía mantenerme como para llegar con
esa vocecita y decirle te lo sientes en
tu cara logré estaba muy contenta
entonces tenía ese sueño también de
venirme a vivir a la ciudad de méxico
porque yo era de provincia
entonces el primer pago que tuve en mi
vida
lo usé para venirme a vivir a la ciudad
de mexico con esta vocecita diciéndome
que importa yo puede salir mal
yo no tenía trabajo y mi hermana tampoco
estos llegamos y empezamos a vivir un
poco de todo lo que se nos presentaba a
mí me llegó la oportunidad de entrar a
estudiar cine con la beca del 100%
entonces empecé a callar esa vocecita
que me decía no puedes no puedes no
puedes empezar a ignorar en lo absoluto
y empieza a decir claro que puedo por
supuesto entonces acepté entrar a
estudiar si me aceptó y conducir un
programa de televisión acepté ser la
protagonista en una obra de teatro nunca
había todo en mi vida acepté hacer unos
comerciales acepté es entregar todas mis
tareas ensayar todos mis diálogos y todo
lo hacía perfecto mentira
obviamente no yo era un absoluto caos y
eso necesita que me decía no puedes no
puedes no puedes esta vez tenía la razón
yo estaba quedando muy mal con la gente
no llegaba tiempo a las cosas me quedaba
dormida y pedía disculpas por quedarme
dormida no me aprendía los diálogos no
contestaba los mensajes y sobre todo
estaba descuidando lo que es más
importante para mí era grosera con mi
mamá era grosera con mis hermanas no le
contestaba a mis amigos y constantemente
tenía que estar pidiendo disculpas por
no llegar por no estar por fallar
entonces entendí que el que importa que
puede salir mal funciona funciona para
cometer los más grandes errores y
algunos aciertos
pero es escuchar a esa vocecita que nos
dice no puedes y entender que es una
vocecita solo una vocecita dentro de tu
cabeza que no es la que debe de dictar
cómo te sientes ni lo que puedes llegar
a hacer
y es horrible que esa vocecita te hable
y te diga esto lo haces mal en mi caso
es el dibujo pero si yo siento que
dibujo mal esa vocecita llega conmigo y
me escupe en la cara cada vez que lo
intento definitivamente entendí que es
encontrar un balance entre estas dos
voces y todavía no lo encuentro o sea el
yo con esa voz que dice claro que sí
acepte dar este texto y con la otra voz
que me decían no puedes me la aprendí
hace cinco minutos así que creo que
salió bastante más o menos bien pero lo
que puedo decirles es que después de que
encuentre esas dos voces y estás quiero
preguntarles cuántas veces
han escuchado a esa vocecita que les
dice no puedes y han dejado de
intentarlo
muchas gracias
[Aplausos]